كانه قصه نجاتهم لوحدها مو معجزه كفايه كل
شويه بتطلع تفاصيل اضافيه صادمه بتزيد
الدراما في القصه نحن بنتكلم تحديدا عن
نجاه الاطفال الاربعه في كولومبيا من بعد
ما بيجيوا اربعين يوم في ادغال غابات
الامازون قصتهم بدات في الاول من مايو لما
نجوا من تحطم طائره صغيره كانوا فيها مع
امهم وقريبهم والطيار وبعدين لقيت السلطات
حطام الطائره وجثث الثلاثه البالغين وما
لقيوا الاطفال الاربعه وبدات عمليات البحث
عنهم اللي استمرت 40 يوم السلطات خلال هذه
الفتره رمت لهم باستخدام الطائرات خرائط
واكل وشرب وماء ودوروا عليهم بكل الطرق في
الغابات الكثيفه حتى شغلوا مكبرات صوت
فيها صوت جدتهم بطلب منهم وتنادي عليهم
الغابات اللي احنا بنتكلم عنها ترى هي جزء
من غابات الامازون موطن لملاجئ ومخابئ
عصابات غير طبعا الحيوانات المفترسه
والخطيره الاولاد اعمارهم 13 و9 13 سنه 9
سنوات اربع سنين وفي رضيع عمره سنه واحده
طيب الكلام كله كان عن الاخت الكبيره لزلي
اللي كانت سبب في انقاذ اخوانها وانتبهت
عليهم وبعد ما لقيهم نقلوهم او نقلوهم
لمستشفى في العاصمه وقالت السلطات انه راح
يبقوا فيها من اسبوعين لثلاثه نظرا طبعا
للحاله الهزيله اللي لقياهم فيها طبعا
يعني طبيعي بعد قاعدين اربعين يوم في
الضياع في غابه يعني الكبار حتى ما بينجوا
منها ففعليا معجزه فعلا انهم طلعوا عايشين
وفي المستشفى وكان في انتظارهم كمان عمهم
وجدتهم وقرايبهم احنا من مشاهدينا شفنا
الصور من لحظات الانقاذ الاولى وشوفنا
فيديوهات نقلهم للمستشفى لكن الجديد نشر
مقاطع للحظات الاولى للعثور عليهم احياء
[موسيقى]
قليله
ومن بعد فرحه النجاه دارت اسئله كثيره في
اذهان الناس عن الاولاد والاربعين يوم
وكيف عاشوا وبدات التفاصيل تتوضح شويه
شويه اولها من فرق الانقاذ اللي شافتهم
نزلي البنت الكبيره وجريت عليهم وقالت لهم
جوعانه جوعانه وواحد من الاطفال الاصغر
صرخ امي ماتت وكان مو قادر يمشي من سوء
التغذيه والحال الصعبه فرق الانقاد قالت
كمان انه اول شيء طلبوا الاولاد هو خبز
ورز بحليب واخبروهم الاطفال كمان انهم
كانوا بيسمعوا صوت المروحيات وبيسمعوا
كمان رسائل جدتهم اللي كانوا يحطوها
بمكبرات الصوت من الطيارات وانهم بقيوا
طول الوقت حوالين النهار علشان الماء مع
الاطفال شنطه اخذوها من اغراض الطياره
البنت الكبيره حاطه فيها خيمه من شفاء
مصباح يدوي بطاريات موبايلين طبعا كلهم
بطارياتهم فاضيه وكمان كان معاهم صندوق
مشروبات غازيه كلها ايضا من الطائره اما
بالنسبه للي كانوا بياكلوه فقالوا الفرق
او قالوا الفرق تحديدا منهم اكلوا حبوب
وفواكه ونباتات بيعرفوها وبيعرفوا انها مو
سامه وبتتاكل كيف عرفوا هذه المعلومه
عرفوها لانهم من السكان الاصليين وبيعرفوا
الغابات والادغال هذه المعلومات اكدها
الزوج الام الراحله وابو اثنين من الاطفال
اللي قال انه لازلي عندها كل مهارات
البقاء على قيد الحياه او انها تعرف كل
شيء وشاطره لكن الجزء الاكثر صدمه في
كلامه هو تفصيله كشفتها
وهو انه الام كانت معاهم اربع ايام وبعدها
ماتت وهي سبب دفعهم للنجاح
في ناس وبابا
يعني مثل ما سمعتو الام بديت عايشه مع
اطفالها اربع ايام ووسط بنتها الكبيره
فيهم يعني حقيقه طبعا تفاصيل محزنه جدا
قالوها للاب الجده كمان كشفت تفاصيل ثانيه
كمان بتقطع القلب فلزلي واخوها اللي عمره
تسع سنوات كانوا هم تايهين بيلعبوا لعبه
متعودين عليها ومعروفه عندهم وبيلعبوها من
زمان واسمها لعبه البقاء على قيد الحياه
وفكرتها انه يدخلوا الغابه ويعملوا بيوت
او ملاجئ من الاشجار حواليهم مثل ورق
الشجر وربطات الشعر والسلطات لقيت فعلا
ربطات شعر وملاجئ عاملينها الاطفال وهم في
الغابه وعلى فكره البنت الكبيره اللزلي
متعلمه معظم هذه المهارات من جدتهم اللي
كانت بتساعد امهم في تربيتهم
[موسيقى]